[Music]
[Applause]
let's go
yeah
we are all sophistic terrorists that's
right ladies and gentlemen we are all
domestic terrorists that's right we're
going to Cedar Rapids
to chill man This coffee's crazy you
should try one of these what are you
drinking I'm just chilling in Cedar
Rapids it's like a donut house like a
K-Cup thing oh I hate those you know
about this dude bro that literally gives
me like PTSD flashbacks to like working
at a like a startup where that's that's
the sweet creamy one oh no I've never
had that you haven't had this because
this is crazy can you make it I don't
like no no I don't like sweet and creamy
and coffee anyway I don't until I break
my fast like a little bit later in the
day
don't own my God me okay you're wearing
a large t-shirt this morning don't
[__] oh my God me
he came in
he came in thinking I wouldn't notice
like he just like showed up with a large
t-shirt I can't even see you don't don't
stand sideways I'm in my large area
you're becoming you're becoming
invisible
well I have this rack of clothing that I
that I have there yeah and uh I told
Lena listen actually I need larges
yeah it smells too big man that's too I
was down I was at 2XL I was almost to
3XL yeah I'm gonna do that yeah I I see
it thank you what are the haters gonna
say when they when they can't say fat
man bad okay fair that's true always for
that that's true I mean we're talking
about the intellectual problems with
people who look at sneako and go like
that's a masculine Alpha Dog yeah
nothing versus I don't think they'll
ever
I don't think they'll ever move past the
fat man bad yeah
um but welcome everybody it's leftovers
thank you Hassan
I thought we were canceled I I thought
we were done uh and then you know
I got the memo I guess like that we
weren't we had we tried to have a
socialist Revolution it got bloody uh
love died yeah yeah
he was skewered by Dan yeah rip to the
goat the Bolshevik no but I'm I'm gonna
abstain from having this conversation
today let's just it's been two episodes
let's get back to the I mean there's
there's a lot happening in the world I'm
always happy and comfortable
conversations that coffee is not good
you're insane probably just try it bro
you said the Donut Hole Coffee is what
is it called it's like no I know exactly
what it is it's like a it's like a like
a door engine it's like a donut right
it's like a sprinkly donut on the top of
the K-Cup I know exactly what it is
right it's like this Staple in every
startup no but you said you haven't
tried it no I have a Nespresso machine
okay I have an espresso machine that
[__] is like literally Primo yeah
exactly that's exactly no just have a
sip I I drink from the Fountain of gods
okay I drink the the naked one please
yeah
I'm used to I I put Prime in all of the
water fountains around my eyes
Prime uh Prime water fun yeah
man that [__] sucks bro they sent us a
bunch of them it's so sweet is this is
so sweet and like you don't want when
it's artificially sweetened then you
really don't want it too sweet you are
you are actually I do agree with you on
that it is it is too sweet artificial
sweetener it does need to strike a
delicate balance that's it and they're
dead and Diet Mountain Dew has struck
that balance and so is Diet Coke uh
Prime not so much well I've been
um playing and diversifying myself in
the zero game and I'll say this Dr
Pepper zero is premium Dr Pepper Zero
Cherry bro they brought all the flavors
together I don't [__] with any Dr Pepper
I've drank it like one time in my entire
life I think I should revisit it I'm
taking a sip but but then here I tried
the the Zero Mountain Dew and here's my
problem with it it's not carbonated
enough
like I pour it interesting and it has
significantly less carbonation than the
other colas that I enjoy and I like
Mountain Dew but I just think they need
to Bubble it up that's actually very
interesting take I've never thought
about it that way I don't really mind it
I love the the radioactive look and feel
to it there's something about it like I
don't know what it is I feel like I'm a
child and I'm drinking like nuka-cola or
something
it's awesome that color is [__] from
another world man but they did it they
do it and we love that huh yeah and it's
illegal in Europe which makes me feel
much better about it root beer zero is
definitely goated okay for your soda
zero go to the [__] okay if you're in
this Euro game why are you they're all
there bro you're touching the weirdest
[__] like you got diet ginger you got
Canada Dry dye Canada Dry is basically I
don't do that it's top shelf okay diet
Canada Dry no caffeine top shelf okay uh
diet Sunkist does have caffeine I used
to think that it didn't but it does
that's pretty decent too if you want
something with a little orange flavor to
it try this just take a step Sprite Zero
is very carbonated I'm just gonna take a
little sip of it just take a clean sip
like a give it a clean step
one pinky up is that why we're doing it
I mean yeah it's it's all right it
tastes like sweetie it does taste like
um yeah it tastes like you're eating
like a glazed donut you're drinking a
glazed donut
thank you back later that's my point
that's intense
[Music]
um but like
I think all the zeros so like this is a
really a fantastic breakthrough in
technology yeah with the zeros I can't
disagree it's just amazing Revolution I
agree we're probably gonna get like that
for that we're gonna get ass cancer in
like 15 years or whatever but I I've
I've realized like that's a l i will
take because man that [__] is so good or
maybe it's not bad for you at all not
that it matters I'm gonna drink a days
away maybe yeah I'm still drinking
cancer and die you son of a [__] I'll
cut your ass hell come to your house and
kill yourself what's wrong with him man
in the words of Donald Trump I'll still
keep I'll keep drinking that garbage you
know
so let's see what do we have today oh
just a short reminder to our uh audience
tickets are on sale tomorrow for our
next live show for members
[Applause]
I think it's Venezuela I don't know I
don't think it's gonna you always say
that a lot more you always say that and
then it always sells and then there's
like a thousand posts in the Reddit
being like
I I had to fight someone with a shank
under a bridge to be able to get my
ticket fupa Troopers have you guys had
the same experience listen I think that
it will sell but I think that the
non-members are gonna get a crack at it
this time that's all which is fine I
don't know I don't think that is going
on I don't think so I think you're 3 300
tickets that's going to say yeah wait
didn't we sell the last one in like
seconds but it was let well it was it
was uh yeah it was more than half the
amount of tickets uh God damn we're
selling this time
yeah slide out over here but if you also
take into consideration what was on the
waiting list for that I mean come there
was a big waiting list too so yeah I
don't know maybe maybe oh yeah and
people that are asking uh what day it's
going to be it'll be on December 17th
oh yeah and I need to say this here
because we're all the he has all box
office sales go to the crew thank you
everybody who says
and as a result of that I just want to
warn everybody this is going to be a
very minimalistic show We're Not Gonna
spend any money right really I don't
think we'll stream it you know that's
right real low key affair
listen we were discussing ticket prices
and ultimately I was like listen it's
kind of up to you guys because it's your
money at the end of the day that's true
that's true but um we all advocated for
uh more affordable prices because we at
the end of the day all care about the
people isn't that right there yeah I
guess we should say too it is a more
expensive venue um not like radically
more expensive but the tickets are a
little bit pricier than that just a
little bit more though right being a
little socialist there dude I don't like
this profit sharing or like you know
decision making process of USA I
literally it's true Ethan Ethan has
given us a cut of all the live show
proceeds for what a [__] fake dude
well people think that they assume that
like the conversation I'm having I'm
literally talking about my business I'm
not
I know talking about whatever let's not
get into it yeah we're gonna chill suck
into it again we're not gonna have a
show but let's see uh bite in
impeachment inquiry uh oh this is
exciting
Dan uh you'll be monitoring this uh this
is breaking news right
uh the impeachment inquiry yeah I was
watching a little bit before the show
um it was all the typical [__] Hunter by
him just being served typical uh not so
typical for the American Congress right
Justice Israeli ever said oh my God they
have my favorite Professor turleyan yeah
uh actually they're already let me go
back and find it there already was a
pretty funny exchange where um this guy
Professor Turley is one of the
Republican Witnesses um well it's funny
because he's not a republican witness
he's just a Fox News legal analyst don't
you mean his uh accreditation no he
Professor James turdley okay he is
literally hardly I assume I assume that
they're just gonna run like everyone
who's been on Fox News like they're just
gonna have the Fox News Brigade at the
stadium at Congress listen this is an
Oprah official
proceeding sanctioned by the Senate with
the full full authority of the
Congressional hearing that they're doing
the American government would never have
a shitty ass Congressional hearing for
no reason other than like you know fun
oh wait hold on actually that's not true
right this is just a couple of people
doing pretend charity I recognize Mr
Frost from Florida for five minutes
thank you Mr chairman an impeachment
inquiry is a grave undertaking that is
supposed to be in response to evidence
of a crime okay Mr chairman you have
questions many of my colleagues Dr Frost
that sounds like a Batman villain I like
that that is a Batman villain no that's
that's Maxwell Frost he's the he's the
Gen Z he's the Gen z uh uh Florida
Democrat that's sick I love Mr Frost
because his name is Frost is first of
all sick
but noted that we need Mr ice special
impeachment Inc sorry that was me my bad
my bad Christmas is one day I'm trying
to find a specific part I saw when I was
kind of half listening this morning one
of the Democrats jumped in and was
questioning Mr Turley and he was
bringing up his uh history as a lawyer
um defending a bunch of Mormons uh
polygamous in Utah and specifically I
guess he he went to bat for this guy
who's a convicted pedophile
and internally responded with something
to the effect of um well I admit I do
have libertarian leanings yeah Tucker
Carlson did that too [__] what's his
name
um that that statement needs to be
analyzed a little bit no Tucker Carlson
is awesome I'm trying to find her at the
time like every conservative shock jock
in the nation was like actually
defending this guy for facilitating
child marriages [__] what's his name I
can't believe the chat will probably
help on this let's crowdsource it well
besides that we'll be checking in on
that um
of the shutdown how's this happening
again man this is embarrassing
government's going to shut down uh you
know it's very real that's a real thing
that's a real thing that that has to
happen
for sure let's see well let me check
that the stock market that's how I know
if it's happening or not S P 500 let's
see no they never it's up so I don't
think it's happening no it doesn't
matter it like even when it shuts down
sometimes the stock market doesn't
respond at this point the stock market
is just propped up by Vibes and The
Vibes are always good in America that's
so that's right it's true all right but
let's talk about some fun stuff before
we get into that for example Jordan
Peterson friend of the show is launching
a college and this is fantastic because
like I think he's well equipped to be a
Headmaster a principal an educator and
he's in a really good State of Mind to
be
um Warren Jeffs was the guy by the way
I'm saying Warren Jeffs yes Warren on
yes kids
the let's discuss what we're doing
panties
Warren Jeff's facilitated child uh
marriages between uh members of his cult
including between children and like
full-blown old ass adults what's your
argument um and then Tucker Carlson and
many of like the conservative
libertarian sickos at the time
straight up went out the bat for him uh
constantly went into like deflections
about like well there's a difference
between child arranged marriages and
like child rape you know like as though
what are we talking
uh I think like 12 13 it was 13 was the
girl he uh yeah was convicted what's the
difference exactly
well that's crazy but they're trying to
find the Nuance okay 13. yeah they're
trying to they're trying to find legally
permissible ways to [__] 13 year olds
which is exactly what they're doing uh
it's the classic like actually it's a
feebophilia argument you know what I
mean it's just well that's even 13 is
cutting it close from that argument the
Jeff's Family Vlog this is actually I
saw this advertised on Fox News it's
pretty cool uh new it's about a Mormon
family they're really wholesome and it's
just about the inner workings of how
what one man has you know like 25 people
oh my God I thought this was real for a
second dude what the hell is happening
I'm next up on the I'm next up on uh
[__] blocking Ethan on Twitter
thinking it's the princess
yeah no this is some Mormon uh cult
where he was like uh screwing kids and
he was trading kids like like currency
other guys Dan you can very easily find
Mormon Carlson defending him by the way
like if you look up Tucker Carlson
Warren Jeffs like he he very clearly
said is like well you know what did he
do that's illegal anyway I mean that's
the country like basically I'd like to
see that uh my internet is not working
on my computer for some reason it's like
very slow
all right well in the meantime let's
let's get a look at Jordan's pitch for
his online university
um let's take a look him and his
daughter dragon energy Michaela herself
this is very slow
starting with Peterson Academy what if
we could make getting a degree 95 less
expensive because yeah
pretty funny Target yeah 95 yeah that's
easy when you have no infrastructure
building it's just online you don't have
accredited you don't do accreditations
you don't have real professors [__] it
should be even less than 95 percent it
should be 99 probably a death probably
before I think the real uh cynical
reason behind this is because thank you
uh in the culture War like everyone is
always going after the the abolition
well Republicans want to abolish
Department of Education that's number
one right that's the first priority
that's why they always go with the
school choice narrative that's why I
always like try to funnel uh public
funds back into charter schools
they want to destroy the teachers unions
um and now the culture War has gotten to
a point where like schools are so under
attack by the Republican party and it's
so well established that like public
school is where you learn homosexual
Marxism yeah that
um like the Republican Boards of
Education in states are comfortable
giving money to Prager you right wait
this happened it's government money
university courses are now being
utilized the kids specifically prayed
your University kids is being utilized
in the State of Florida in the state of
Oklahoma and if I'm not mistaken New
Hampshire is one of the other states
that's like slowly implementing it like
phasing it in like do we have an example
of what they're using from Prager U yes
they do Media Matters did a deep dive
into all the page review kids stuff I've
looked at it on the stream as well it is
disastrously bad it's just some dumb ass
with a YouTube channel by advocating for
incest I don't understand it's worse
than that it is uh dumb answer the
YouTube channel advocated for incest
with uh with animation let me watch one
of these to see what's happening here
and
publicly fun I'll try and uh I'll try
and pull one here any second yeah I mean
that that is pretty cynical I think
Jordan just trying to get paid on the
backs of this sentiment you're saying
yeah there's like a Robert E Lee one
which is pretty funny I think that
they're like they get together uh two
generals and like they're like yeah you
were just misunderstood
we just had a simple disagreement but I
really respect you
Robert E Lee and I learned a lot about
Robert E Lee in school like you know he
was you know good guy misunderstood he
was a great General they said and we
need statues of him up uh outside of
courthouses every Courthouse yeah man of
the law and um we need to basically uh
worship him he was upholding the law
right
and law is always right it's the blue
line baby yeah
he was upholding uh Heritage and not
hate 95
after a better quality experience along
the way why wouldn't it be good to wait
did you get everybody in there
and talk about birds evolutionary
science did you put the music or did
they do that I did not do that let me
see if it's on his channel wait this is
him this is him this is all that's the
ominous ass music that makes it look
like they're they're a university for
for villains
he's very Joker it literally looks like
what are they teaching like how to be a
bond villain what the [__] happening
here
let's hit let me hear again that would
be sick it's like we're gonna undercut
You by 95 and offer a better that's
crazy ominous
it's like hitting that that uh
apocalyptic cello nice good I feel like
conservatives are on their villain [__]
like they they are just straight up like
no we're the bad guys and that's cool
you gotta have the good and the bad so
I'll be the bad guy you've made me this
way that's it it's murdering himself The
Experience along the way why wouldn't it
be good to provide everybody at least in
principle with access to the best
lectures you know you might think why
should you be generally educated because
otherwise you're going to be a user why
is this like a fever dream like they're
cutting it more and more like he's
rambling it reminds me of like Willy
Wonka in the [__] the boat ride of
Madness this is unnecessarily scary
lectures that are almost always going to
revolve around like transgenders are
actually morally wrong and you need to
stop you need to stop doing that no more
wokeness I mean what do you think they
talked about in ever evolutionary
biology if you look at the bird there's
not one transgender bird third take a
look yeah this is 100 uh going to be a
biological predeterminism 101 that like
you know that that subtly gets into like
95 cheaper
it'll it'll subtly get into race realism
but like not fully invest itself in it
and just be like yeah I mean we're just
uh biologically predetermined to be uh
to and we've evolved in a way to be uh
right-wing capitalist it's just normal
it's good
um natural this is
this is phenomenal let's see
at least in principle with access to the
best lectures you know you might think
why should you be generally educated
because otherwise you're going to be
what the [__]
resentful bitter pointless
counterproductive love which is
hilarious because that's who he is and
he's been educated well he's Rich so so
sometimes when you're rich you're just
right by default yeah okay not if you're
a socialist
he literally said Nazis were worse than
socialists and and it's not even a
contest the other day he said it's not
even a contest like we can't compare
them yeah he was like by by he's like
it's it's really hard to be worse than
the Nazis but the Socialists somehow did
it USSR probably but even then it's just
like pure a historical like nonsense
that literally borderlines uh Hitler
apologia at that point it's like if you
are looking at a situation on the one
side you have the Nazis on the other
side you have the guys who killed the
most Nazis and you say the guys who
killed the most Nazis are actually worse
than the Nazis you're just doing
Holocaust apologia yeah the USSR was
pretty bad though I I agree but there's
a major difference between what the [__]
sorry
um there's a major difference between uh
uh saying like due to uh political due
to authoritarian struggles due to
political struggles due to uh economic
struggles lack of planning and the like
that uh an entire system that was trying
to collectivize over the course of you
know uh 100 years in comparison to the
400 years of collectivization that the
Western capitalist Nations have engaged
in with slavery and brutal conquests in
in the form of colonialism
um the there's going to be hiccups not
not all of it is excusable for the
record obviously it's not but like
comparing that to deliberate ethnic
cleansing and then saying the other side
is worse especially when like it's not a
it's not an argument I would necessarily
want to put out there you know what I
mean yeah especially at a time when the
[__] Canadian Parliament literally
had a straight up SS guy do you see that
no
oh you didn't oh you didn't hear about
that no it was a big yikes wait what
happened there the Canadian Parliament
uh the speaker of the parliament brought
a actual Waffen SS Galicia division what
Ukrainian volunteer Nazi that's 98 years
old
oh [__] and everybody gave him a
standing ovation wait wait wait wait
wait because of Ukraine because they
they missed the point on that one a
little bit bro they prom they presented
it no this guy was like I never thought
I would get a standing oh and yeah no
Society this is beautiful I'm crying no
in that moment he was like oh my God we
lost the battle but we won the war
what's happening yeah he actually uh he
resigned as a result of it uh yesterday
the the speaker wait I want to see the
clip of this this is such a Kevin James
meme uh face that he's making yeah when
you accidentally bro this guy's in his
writing right uh and he's like oh uh you
know this is my guy I want to celebrate
him as like a Ukrainian veteran right so
he presents them in Parliament as such
he says we have a wonderful you know
bold beautiful brilliant Ukrainian
veteran who fought in World War II and
up to this point like okay great no he
did say it he literally said he fought
in World War II against Russia and oh
that's at that moment everyone's like
wait a minute what against Russia that's
right bro yeah this man has been against
Russia his whole life yeah and and it's
kind of funny because like now the
Polish officials
after him man dude it's like it's like
that's awesome this guy volunteered in
the in the SS Foreigner Brigade like
went to Nazi Germany trained there went
back talked about in a blog post for
Ukrainian veterans yeah in Canada
because there's like a big diaspora
right uh wrote in 2010 that the
Holocaust the years in which the
Holocaust were happening were some of
the best years of his life yeah those
are His Glory Days man if only I could
go back to those good times simpler
times yo he's like um
he's like Nazi rookie Trading Card Mint
Condition boy yeah yeah he's a PSA 10
dude
he's just it's crazy here's the cam just
sent it hold on I gotta see this
so did this guy who brought him out who
resigned he he said he didn't realize he
didn't know they all know it's [__]
ridiculous but then he resigned so I'm
confused about his what the [__] he
thought would happen we have here I mean
is it possible it's just a massive [__]
up no I know I know exactly what it is I
can't imagine he would willingly bring a
Nazi out no there okay well then he
resigned why would he the Ukrainian uh
diaspora or the Canadian Ukrainian
diaspora and uh it's it's like uh
questionable uh figures or depictions of
of uh Nazis is is not this is not the
first time it's happened there's two
different places where like
um they've built memorials like like a
lot of times when you look at like
victims of Communism memorials like they
do this sneaky thing where they add the
Nazis in there as well as like victims
of Communism and not necessarily like
victims of famine or whatever you know
what I mean it's like literally they
will put like actual Nazis
um in two different instances in Canada
uh there were two memorials I forget the
exact names uh of the of the two
different memorials but like both of
them were were on the Nazi side
in in one of the districts they wrote
literal Nazi Memorial on it in red
graffiti paint
and the police launched a hate crime
investigation huh
the police launched a hate investigation
no literally
India covered it they immediately
dropped it because they're like oh [__]
what are we doing and then in another in
another District uh there was a
progressive journalist in Canada who was
writing about these like is it possible
the police didn't know it's a Nazi and
they just thought they were being like
derogatory
so like he's not a Nazi I mean
maybe they should have done an
investigation before launching one right
I mean just Googling instead I mean they
were trying to tell them but but my
point is um I think this is a lot of
like anti-communist anti-socialist
fervor in the western world that like uh
gets a lot of people swept up and and
causes them to forget like
what the alignment looks like uh uh in
regards to who you are offering support
to because like oh they're an
anti-communist I'm an anti-communist
like we're we're friends we're allies
you know what I mean that's usually the
attitude Without Really realizing like
oh [__] this guy's like straight up Nazi
because those were the major
anti-communists right you know like uh
the early the Early German generals that
were brought on to Nato actually I've
been hearing uh Whispers of um
a celebration honoring the greatest
anti-russian War Warrior
Hitler yeah yeah I mean we're we're
still removed from that
I think he's still seen as like the
ultimate Evil you know luckily holy [__]
so let me see this this dude really came
up here in this goofy outfit to defend a
Nazi let's see bro some people were
trying to [__] why wasn't he wearing
he was wearing his goofy outfit why
wasn't the veteran wearing his uniform
when do you ever see veterans true when
do you ever see veterans in an official
setting not wear their uniform Ethan a
question one must ask usually they were
they're proud of that yeah trying to
show it off why does this man have two
book markers on his
on his chest
that's the rock coat that is like
actually
um shows how the D work where uh on
Twitter uh that is like the original uh
Elite outfit where suits and ties
apparently were the commoners Garb and
this was the original Outlet outfit of
uh Elites we shot we should go back
yeah I think the high neck the high
neckline frock uh and and whatever that
[__] Thai thing is all right let's
see what this guy has to say
Ukrainian Canadian World veteran
from the second world war who fought the
Ukrainian Independence against the
Russians say what
hmm
okay bro knowing what he fought for
Ukrainian Independence against the
Russians against the Russian Nazis truck
was that something they did for Ukraine
or something okay that's even funnier
and even more sad uh yes and no there
were Ukrainian nationalists uh of
varying different backgrounds that
thought oh we can just align with the
Nazis and they'll give us independence
and the Nazis were like you're a slav
dog what are you talking about you're
not even human in my eyes so they
literally arrested half of the [__]
Ukrainian nationalists although they
were still uh facilitating in the uh in
the uh pogroms uh you know doing the
Holocaust and also a lot of anti-polish
uh like they killed a [__] ton of Polish
people too this guy is really like
they're looking to extradite the worst
part about this guy has Noah he's like
what is happening this is awesome the
worst part of it I want to kill all
these people the worst part about the
story is that like obviously ukrainians
uh what was I think the official number
is like an insane number of ukrainians
uh were in the front of the the Red Army
like ukrainians were fighting the Nazis
right at the time a much smaller number
were aligning with the Nazis and these
[__] still somehow find a way
to be like yeah that's those are the
guys that we're gonna prop up here is
this our boy here who's being honored
yeah yeah he's got his own Wikipedia
page right that sent me the Wikipedia
after but they got this they got the
lightning balls they got the swazi is
that Kanye yeah you can't even do that
no no no like no it's not that's
somebody else you can't even do like the
the clean Vermont Theory which I don't
agree with anyway but you can't even do
that for him because he literally
volunteered for the Waffen SS Foreigner
Brigade I'm sorry but like this is proof
among this is proof there's no God this
Nazi lived to be 20 98 and then to be
honored in the Canadian Parliament Henry
Kissinger also alive and well all right
you know okay that's true yeah that's
true yeah no
five-year-olds are dying of leukemia
yeah and Dick Cheney who's literally
looks like the human embodiment of
cardiovascular doesn't have a heart he
doesn't have a heart he got the infernal
engine yeah he does not have a heart
like there's like eight different
batteries pumping blood in his in his
body
and and also big penis
yeah he is a fat [__] where did that
room how do we know that I've seen it
what I don't know why I said it like
I've seen it in person but I did talk
about this on the show what was it in
his pants it was just it was just like
there was a there was a picture where
you could kind of see his balls and it
was like um the rumor is really that uh
Dick Cheney send me that so Dick Cheney
is like of not a great background like
originally he's like a lineman uh you
know putting up uh electrical and
telephone poles and stuff and he's like
a [__] great background like his
background is not uh similar to like a
lot of the elites uh came up he's a
working class yeah he's a working class
guy who's like a real and and a real
piece of [__] too like he would get in
the [__] fights like he's gotten
arrested for drunk driving at a time
when like let me see it it's basically
legal can we even bro are you sure
that's his pack it looks like his
diapers hanging like I have kids and
that's what it looks like when they're
diving
that's like I like the theory that he
[__] his pants too
when he was in college why is it so it's
so Hefty in college he used to uh pose
in the nude for art student and they
call him Big Dick Cheney
oh okay wait so there's like documented
evidence of it yeah they saw it who's he
talking to why is he flexing on the ice
cream man dude ice cream guy like like
bro you got a dress that's a soda jerk
that's what that is that's how old he is
yeah and it's like it was old when there
were Soda Jerks yeah that's like a dying
thing now there's no there's no more
soda look at this don't you all think
that
there's two it looks like he's torqued
like
it's two it's two there's too much why
do you think his heart can't pump any
[__] blood into it in the rest of his
body his cock's too fat he's suffering
too full bro I don't know he's Suffering
From Success dog that's what's going on
all right Big Dick Cheney Shrek [__]
well he's got a big dick to [__] Iraq
with and all the that's right you know
what I mean thank you thank you true so
anyway back to this [__] idiot
all right
and continues to support the troops
today
[Music]
what a guy
standing though
dude everyone did it
like every [__] in there was
like hell yeah wait the lenski is in
there yeah oh they didn't know right I
mean they didn't know like nobody has a
lot of people she wouldn't you know I
mean that's what I mean though like you
didn't [__] think about it when he
says like he's a anti-russian
nationalist like what are we doing here
well I think that I hear that I
immediately have red flags like like
alarm bells are ringing in my brain I'm
like what wait but for sure they
wouldn't expect him to actually honor
standing oh
meanwhile dude he's doing the Ohio
Hitlers bro no no he doesn't no he's not
yo he's going Heil Hitler
look at that his hand
towards the Habit the muscle memory is
coming back a little bit
wait till you find out that Kyle Hitler
he's like I cannot believe this [__]
what he's like
he's like that was close
oh what the [__] how did they let this
happen this is so [__] embarrassing
this is so embarrassing you know what's
really funny because like everyone's
like oh Justin Trudeau what a [__]
idiot who did that right like everyone's
dunking on him and then like including
even the NDP you know shouts out you
know I I listen
uh jug meat uh I've I've supported him
before you know he's my homie but I'm
sorry every single [__] in the
parliament was was giving him a standing
o including the conservative party which
was really funny because they
immediately started cutting attack ads
and people were like bro you're on
camera celebrating they were like this
guy did a standing up yeah he was like
yeah like the guy who was doing this
[__] five minutes ago is now tweeting
on Twitter being like Justin Trudeau
you're a [__] idiot like I can't
believe you brought a Nazi indoor
Parliament the best part is that the the
authorities in Poland are like we found
him yeah
we need him yeah wait till you find out
by the way they just introduced Deputy
Prime Minister Christia freelins
grandfather is a Nazi collaborator who
she openly is aware of and a nose and
and has defended to this day I I don't
think you can write this [__] it's like
it does have an air of like curses
why are you being like that Alfredo oh
he wants to play here I'm gonna put you
down what's your uh
he's scared like kg Alfredo why are you
being so what's um you had a you had a
nickname for him when he gets like that
oh frickco that's right he goes alfriko
mode yeah he gets all Frick though but
he's usually really sweet with dogs
yeah Kai is a big baby so that's
probably why that makes sense she's a
big girl
come over here
I'm gonna put you down come cuddle with
me
you guys are you guys can be friends
Alfredo you guys have you guys have met
so many times already
Kai just wants to play Alfredo I know
she's she's scary because she's so big
she's just a baby it's okay Alfredo she
is a baby she's a big baby just a big
baby he's a friend alfredo
yeah she just wants to play I'm so
worried when she gets her first period
oh God yeah it's gonna be a [__]
massive issue for me it's okay right she
just wants that's the thing you got to
deal with isn't it I'm gonna have to get
her diapies she wants to play Oh They'll
be kind of cute at least it apparently
it goes you get diapers
especially yeah bigger dogs especially
like they bleed a lot apparently wow I
mean her shits are like human size so I
suspect that her period will also be
is 80 pounds right you're gonna drive
all the dogs at the park crazy no I'm
not gonna let her out dogs would be
running from like blocks no the she
actually the problem is that they get
aggressive from what I understand and
the first like really yeah they get like
really really violently aggressive
against male dogs and then in the second
week
um they get aggressive towards female
dogs uh when they're ready to mate
Kai is laying down with alfredo see
that's very sweet Kaya you see Alfredo
she's big but she's nice she's big but
she's nice okay
okay
good boy
you did it you facilitated piece let's
see though afraid of she's so nice she
just wants to say hi even the Diplomat
Give It Up
that's soft power right there
flexing
good boy Alfredo she she just wants to
lay with you how nice is that huh
um
car is not the best with little dogs she
she always wants to play with them like
uh she's really good with big dogs
she'll play with them all day every day
but little dogs don't want to play with
her she's really big yeah the frail's a
little cagey too since Shredder
passed away he doesn't know how to act
because he took all this leader anymore
leader of the pack
all right but uh anyway uh that was a
fun little uh I'm enjoying it I want a
random side Journey that we took with
like uh Canada's Nazi oopsie can we
please continue yeah no I want to watch
it
and I hope they actually died him to
Poland Gallery how can they not
oh no okay well Canada Canada does not
like extraditing people what are they
going to say countries I think in this
case exception that'd be really funny
dude I hope it happens I hope he gets
hanged dude that'd be fixed that or is
that like a technical issue it's a
technical issue okay just a little
technical issue here we have some
technical issue it sounds like we do
about it what are we gonna do
[Music]
side all right you want Justice to be
certain I don't know if I got it I might
have waited I think it was less than 20
seconds
Justice to be served uh and if the uh if
the punishment for it is is capital
punishment then maybe that'll happen
it's out of your hand there that's a
mortgage thing what is the punishment oh
dude you literally buttoned it right
after like I just saw it Oh no well I
said I hope he gets hanged dude now you
just said it again but well but but he's
a Nazi
can't we hang Nazis I mean historically
yes that's what we do that
I don't know I was just uh yeah
trials
are trying to say is that hopefully
Justice is served
Ethan's being mean to Nazis try that
you really you really think in in our
liberal landscape [__] aren't
gonna come at you and be like wow wow
you want to say killed his 98 year old
man who look at how pleasant he is he
just got a standing oh you know and I'm
not even talking about like oh you're
not here no this guy was literally a
member of the Nazi party I'm sorry like
I'm not even this isn't like an
interpreter I agree I'm just YouTube is
a little crazy
funny if they hang it because he's so
old this will be the wildest way to get
banned yeah right like getting a strike
over this would be that would be
something yeah he's at the top of the
mountain being applaud and then he's
gonna
he flew way too close to the Sun dog you
can't be you can't be that confident
like what are you doing you were a
[__] Nazi bro he wrote a blog post
like it's an 80. like you know what I
mean like this [__] wasn't
hiding it either you know that's the
crazy he's like a vampire he stepped out
into the sunlight thinking it wouldn't
get him yeah but you know like thank you
it's it's your move YouTube it's me or
the Nazis you decide
you failed it Wesley has always sighted
against the Nazis either right yeah
to be like your your comments about
killing not you know to Hanging Nazis a
protected group
yeah
historical events at the Nuremberg Trial
what happened what we were doing yeah
it'd be really funny it's like
betterhelp.com wants everyone to get
access to therapy including Nazis which
is why that was not very cool of you you
know um
the thing is
that I don't I'm not pro hanging's
barbaric I don't think it should happen
I agree if anything he should just be
thrown off a cliff or something
and when they don't die you hit him with
the [__] Sledgehammer yeah yeah no
but like in terms of weight I mean if
you throw them off a high enough click
then it's just lights out yeah and you
have time to reflect you know maybe I
shouldn't have killed all those people
time to regret hanging is barbaric yeah
it just sucks because you can't go back
in time like he already lived that
moment where he was like damn like did
we win like what's happening right right
I really hate to say this I think
there's someone hanging right there ah
yes but the Canadian Parliament be like
Logan when did you become the Canadian
uh you know Canadian Parliament
but I'm very proud to say that he is
from North Bay and from my riding of
nicotine he's proud dude go to your aunt
this is my favorite thing that's
happened this year it's so funny look at
how happy he is
see this is why I say like
and I don't know how but like
I feel like he couldn't have known he
couldn't have known I I I still think he
should resign I mean obviously that's
such an embarrassing I know exactly what
it is I'm telling you it's the
anti-communist fervor they like people
get so invested in where they forget
that like there was a time when you know
the USSR was aligned with the Allied
powers and was you know doing great
stuff in terms of killing Nazis you know
so worldwide when you forget that uh you
know when you when you're so swept up
with like anti-communism anti-socialism
and like you're so [__] aggro you
forget that like you're aligning
yourself with Nazis and then you know
that also leads me into the development
of NATO when Germany was brought into
NATO they literally took German Nazi
generals and put them in charge of NATO
right like because they were the most
rugged
uh experience at the resume yeah they
had a resume of of anti-communition they
had a great battles so they they put
them in positions of power this is my
face at the Nuremberg Trial when they
hang the Nazis
I see no no I'm trying it wasn't on the
screen I thought it was going to cut to
either Kevin James or or the
chiropractor lady yeah that's what I
should have yeah that's what I should
have done now they're just having so
much fun dude with the Nazis he's a
Ukrainian hero a Canadian hero what am I
yeah hey oh yeah I'm the worst person
remember when the United States
government invaded Germany
yeah they killed a whole bunch of
Germans I just want to hang one Nazi no
not I don't want to do it but I mean
technically you're right they I mean the
scale of them they were pretty good on
the scale of things
you want only one not as many as the
American well I'm saying you know uh
yeah
it's just like a little cleanup it's
just a little follow-up yeah maybe let's
um move on let's get on to control we're
talking about Jordan Peterson what
happened
we're talking about Canadian Nazi yeah
literally said
basically what's happening right there
but he he verbalized it in an even more
clear and concise way where he was like
oh you know USSR is worse by worse than
the Nazis and that's not that's a tough
competition I just have to say that guy
looks so [__] proud yeah
he's like we did it yeah he had the we
did it Joe face
we did it Joe you got all these people
like look what I've done Nazi
uh listen um if I get in trouble for
saying that I'll happily take a break
yeah man I guess what's the expectation
there like YouTube's like hey when you
come back from your break you better not
[__] say that Nazis should be
criminally tried and then at the end of
it maybe face uh capital punishment
for their crimes right yeah
[Music]
I hit the button stop don't push no more
pushing I just wanted to make that right
up to the edge I just wanted to make
that clear yeah I'm only talking about
members of the Nazi party that's it he's
not back that maybe I should just let
you cook so we get a break yeah okay
yeah we all need a break man
the studio today smells like like
buttermilk waffles it's my coffee is it
is it the coffee somebody might have
been cooking somebody's off I've been
cooking I think all this Nazi [__] I
think it's the coffee
by the way this is his face after The
Gallows is done
oh dude oh
oh you saw you know this one of course
dude I hate the chiropractor videos oh
my God I have I'm doing a war against
chiropractors I think they're the
biggest quacks alive right now I think
their whole profession should be fully
on board with everything you're saying I
mean it's just they're these guys are
just scammers and they hurt people yeah
they paralyze people look what you did
to this poor woman man I don't know he's
treating her like a ex-nazi party member
man okay okay let's move on I won't even
subject I should have never shown this
to you God damn it I I'm I take full
responsibility I'm sorry everybody all
right Jordan go ahead go ahead strategy
so that's why you think you think so
that your stupid thoughts can die what
you think so that your stupid thoughts
can die he's so he's such a skilled
order he's so powerful love it instead
of you if you get to the upper echelons
hierarchy she's got her phone in she was
born dude she's reading tweets look at
her phone thanks so that you're stupid
you ever seen a serious my queen she can
do no wrong if you look at this phone
placement is interesting oh my God
you're right scratch that what the [__]
I don't know I mean what the [__] is
that
you know I did not notice it because I'm
not a misogynist and I thought she was
in deep thought right well I just looked
at it and thought and you were looking
at her eyes I was looking at her brain
yeah I'm so much less misogynist than
anybody I was looking at her soul
yeah like Shallow Hal yeah exactly what
a great reference great movie people say
shallow house misogynistic
you'll start encountering people who
know a lot about almost everything and
so if you're stupid and you don't know
anything about anything they're just
gonna look at you and listen to you for
like two seconds and think well I don't
know where this clunk came from but you
know he's not come along for the ride
you need to be enculturated so that you
can play with sophisticated people and
you can play a sophisticated and
productive game but also so that you've
informed yourself with the greatest
ideas of History so that whatever
problem you're tackling you're going to
have tools to tackle it with once we get
it well developed damn there's okay
we're gonna we're gonna learn so we
gotta talk about these people to be
sophisticated
it's just the list is a little light I
feel like but you know there's there's a
lot of other sophisticated people that
Jordan Peterson has uh declared uh
firmly in the uh Frankfurt uh uh school
of thought and and is
um you know they're they're doing uh
cultural bolshevism well he doesn't say
cultural bolshevism uh he or he says uh
what does he say [__] no cultural
Marxism cultural yeah right Marxism yeah
yeah
take all these courses and then you know
you won't be a complete embarrassment to
yourself I didn't enjoy my University
experience the professor wasn't
interesting I was like I'm pretty sure
what they just said wasn't true yo bro
she's so bold oh she's she's so
brilliant because they lived in cages
literally that happened she said hold on
hold on wait what wait what did you tell
me social creatures because they lived
in cages
rats weren't social creatures because
they okay so what I love the I love the
presentation I have some context rats
will dance for money I love the
presentation of this because they're
she's like saying like I Googled
something that my professor said and I
found out that like you know I got the
woke mind virus like I found out that my
professor was like lying to me
about rats and being social cruises
which by the way we have no idea if that
actually happened or not like I'm pretty
sure there was more context than that
her professor's like did you know rats
aren't social creatures you guys it's
really funny to say this to Jordan
Peterson because Jordan Peterson gets
pretty much everything wrong uh all the
time when he tries to talk about things
that are completely outside of his field
where like whenever he tries to talk
about like animals specifically uh to to
reinforce like this uh you know gay
Birds is this uh natural uh this
naturalistic fallacies uh he he often
forgets that you know the animal kingdom
is gay as [__] for example or even very
queer very trans or I want to obviously
I saw my two male dogs having sex man I
mean they they got off big time on that
I didn't have to leave my home to see it
yeah they love that [__] man they go
dick to dick dick you know I mean all
different dick whatever [__] my dog
all I just knew there was only two dicks
and lots of humping
I did not come on my door here okay all
right all right
not traveling 40 minutes to go to this
class and I think it's cruel that people
are told they have to go to university
they have to spend 100 to 200 000 to get
a degree so they can get a job otherwise
they're screwed it's just a scam but it
bothers me that people are being scammed
to learn to not believe in themselves in
a sense she's right that college has
become a scam but what's the best part
is they're going to be like okay so
let's not do that again let's do this
yeah let's do an even bigger scam than
like at least accredited institutions
this one you get nothing for yeah no
it's great I mean this has already
happened obviously Barry Weiss did this
with uh the the Texas uh what the [__]
was that she did one in Austin Texas
basically uh and and it's a massive
failure so far but like I said I think
the the cynical the cynic in me looks at
this and thinks there's a profit motive
definitely and I think that the reason
why they're doing these like
unaccredited institutions is because
they believe that like uh the next wave
of uh conservatives and positions of
power we'll just offer them fat
government contracts uh to to just churn
out like right-wing agit prop that they
will pump in our schools Jordan seems
very motivated on by money I've seen and
heard him say certain things
oh what I was like man this guy seems to
like
solely motivated by money yeah well ah
there's another motivation out there
it's called benzos well and yeah those
ain't cheap man when you got a heavy
habit tell you what boy
you know what's a Stick Run on the
street like 20 bucks
I [__] don't know what I'm saying
it would be funny by the way we could
this is my face when um
I finally find out I don't have to go to
college but I can just go to Jordan
Peterson's college instead oh God it's
so cursed
as the Nazi he's having such a great
time he's so happy well apart the
university system a little bit he's just
broken
[Music]
into your job basically you'll be
still milk in this [__] man my favorite
six years ago crazy my favorite thing
this is what Trump does really well as
well he takes personal Grievances and
people like sliding him for behaving in
an inappropriate manner in like polite
society and he turns that into like
structural critique that like the elites
aren't simply saying no you're not
allowed to be in our circles because
you're uh you know you're you're rude or
you're kind of gross you're right uh
it's not that that's happening it's
actually uh that like Elites have
disdained for me because I'm I'm a part
of the working class just like you and
Jordan Peterson has done this as with
very well as well he has a way of
communicating his own personal
grievances that is absolutely motivated
by uplifting his brand uh where you know
he just wanted to be [__] transphobic
he's got a lot of like backwards
right-wing reactionary ideas that are
outright either a historical when it
comes to plenty of the uh Circle
background that he offers with respect
to like Nazis and and socialists and
whatnot or reactionary when he talks
about the the biological predeterminist
uh opinions that he has about like male
and and female uh social hierarchy and
how they are supposed to habitate spaces
so those are genuine opinions that he
has and he's a stubborn [__]
as most professors are and he won't give
up so inevitably there's like going to
be a lot of people that were protesting
against him any and and he became
further and further openly more and more
openly right-wing and now this this
personal Conquest that he has against
like University of Toronto and all these
other like uh academic institutions that
have uh you know banished him in his
words
uh he he must attack back and the best
way to do that most effective way to do
that is by saying they're not just after
me they're after me because uh they're
after you I'm just in the way
right classic Trump phenomena and I mean
I don't know man he's still taught this
would be like if I was still complaining
about YouTube demonetizing my Joey
salads video five years ago or some [__]
it's like I don't know man it's just
time to move on a little bit and if you
literally made a killing off of that you
know what I mean if you made like right
yeah
salads University yeah if you made tens
of millions of dollars over the course
of this past like half a decade and and
became profoundly successful like went
from a relatively uh unknown aggressive
can opening I've ever heard in my life
yeah all right because I shake it oh you
do
can provide you with a list of people
who've graduated and if you had any
sense you'll employ them preferentially
because we did the rigorous screening
work and I know how to do the radio
screen work because I studied that this
is a Tim Heidecker character isn't it
yeah that delivery was insane but he
said so his his theory is if you come to
my school you're gonna get yeah that
your employees are gonna look at your
your pseudo degree from Jordan Peterson
University can hire you immediately yeah
also this he's saying take my word for
it he's gonna say it I'm gonna screen
people that are allowed in like [__]
you're gonna take money and let anyone
in who wants shut up kidding me but look
at this Tim Heidecker sketch
you'll be damn fortunate if we can
provide you with a list of people who've
graduated and if you had any sense
you'll employ them preferably right oh
he's speaking to the employers
I know how to do it because I started
because I did it myself for 25 years
University
will signify he's a confidence man this
is just a con those
are very and the difference is like
unlike Andrew Tate he's like not even
entertaining it's for he's Andrew Tate
for uh the the he's interested for a
different generation of people who at
least want like the the presence of
pseudo-intellectuals like annotate at
least is like straight up you know he's
like women are [__] they're [__]
you should kill them with a knife or
whatever the [__] he says right whereas
like Jordan Peterson will will go on
these like convoluted tangents about how
like we simply do not know how women and
men cohabitate in spaces like we haven't
had you know hundreds of thousands of
years of development on that front
um this is launching in November of this
year that gives them like basically one
month to finish this and this to me is
looking like WordPress first day of a
website and that huh like what the [__]
yeah looking totally complete like
what's the deal with this like the extra
stock art up there learn from the
world's best
how to think not what to think
how much do you think they're going to
charge for this dude it's gonna be a lot
it's gonna be a few thousand
because that's it you know you have to
make them feel like they're getting
something valuable awesome because if
you just charge like 10 bucks then then
oh good point it won't feel like a real
Edge right like a real school like like
it is
exactly
um anyway that's taken a long time ago
here's Tim pulls Russell Brand take I
don't know is Temple getting Dumber
um he's becoming more dumb and more
hateful to the to the point where what's
this guy's name again
oh Andy no so Andy no is like somehow
the voice of reason in this clip yeah
that really tells you where Tim is at
this point Tim is lost oh my God no what
a name what happened to this guy I
thought he was like being attacked
mercilessly by antifa he got milk shaked
into Oblivion yeah he got milkshake so
hard he almost died and then it was in
the milkshake it was this it was a
cement it was an advanced cement
compound yeah
it's just weird because like they went
to court for that and I'm pretty sure he
didn't win that court case so I guess
Justice is on the side of antifa on that
front you know antifa judges they took
the dub yeah anyway here's Tim Poole
I reject all of the uh accusations and
allegations against Russell Brand all
right thank you well that's a that's an
Enlightenment yeah that's a nuanced take
from Temple I appreciate that oh no he
won
I thought I thought he Lo he lost one
lawsuit and he won one lawsuit he won
300K from defendants who ignored lawsuit
over Poland uh Portland protest beating
wait what did he win for
um
Andy yes he won he won one of the
lawsuits and he lost the other one but
what so what did he win on
what did the judge find
this is such a funny thing because if
you look up Andy no court case there's
like three articles on there's like Fox
News article saying he wanna he scored a
legal uh he scored a legal win and then
their civil liberties defense center is
like Andy no loses lawsuit
all right we'll look at Portland jury
finds no fault for two activists at
trial
but let's look into it I want to focus
on this Temple okay he says no matter
what I support Russell which is
beautiful I mean it's it's a pattern in
but one of them went to a Rape Crisis on
her oh no Andy no no no don't say that
bring that up
at the time and and considering the
political state of this country
considering the actions being taken
against them considering the motivations
of the press
sure but sure yeah she went she did a
rape sure fine whatever you know sure
this happened like wow four years ago
before he worked for you know before he
even pivoted into right-wing Grifton
give the benefit of the doubt sorry not
nothing [__] there's it's not a
benefit of the doubt situation
he's not giving her the benefit of the
doubt
he says I don't believe women shut up
okay women be lying right there are so
many people shopping they be lying bad
people and criminals who are getting
away with everything that what we end up
seeing is law enforcements choose to go
after certain people when it benefits
them politically yes that's the nature
of the West why aren't we going after
the bad guys instead of uh investigating
Russell Brand we cannot do both in this
vast vast country with thousands of
different police departments and federal
agencies famously the the British police
is it it doesn't have any like
well-documented investigations on how
they've routinely no uh thrown aside or
engaged in a victim blaming it at a
systematic level in rape cases uh in the
UK certainly certainly no such uh thing
has existed
look at this
I'm being sarcastic that did happen
um the the the British police uh had to
investigate the British police because
of their uh you know routine misconduct
and sexual assault cases this is not
worth the effort
and Tim's uh and Tim's uh opinion this
is this is jordison uh uh Academy here
guys it's basically just a um
what do you call those videos where it's
like girl dates cut the cuts he's doing
cut he's charging for cut videos you
know you can watch this for free on
YouTube man
I love that the top response is a
question is it accredited no comment no
51 weeks no comment let's not talk about
that yeah
and then the second one
yeah man this is great wow yeah it's
huge
yeah
so when I see 20 year old accusations
it's Brett Kavanaugh all over again
sorry don't care at all you want to
investigate you want to prove it by all
means please do this yeah
well yeah none of these are first of all
that's a separate thing obviously I
believe that if somebody raped someone
20 years ago especially someone under
the age of 18.
like she was sick that's what they
always they keep ignoring they go they
they always do this they go yes it's
gross to have sex with a 16 year old
ignoring the whole that thing that he he
raped her and he groomed her all
documented yeah that's uh it's it's
pretty wild but also expected you know
conservatives are pro
uh pedophilia it seems like I mean when
have they not been I think it's just
straight up conservatives the difference
between like Libertarians who will
openly say that like the age of consent
law should be abolished or whatever the
[__] like the New Hampshire libertarian
party uh Twitter account who's run by
literally a woman dating a [__]
convicted pedophile who's in prison
serving a sentence for uh child
endangerment okay sometimes they'll be
open about it sometimes they'll engage
in the actually it's a feebophelia so
it's okay uh argument but others the
more mainstream conservatives will
oftentimes defend not direct pedophilia
not direct like uh sexually assaulting
minors statutory rape but instead will
say well you know child marriages are an
adequate formation like it's much better
than like other forms of of [__]
children
you know it's like where are we getting
into this like you can't say it's bad
like it's it's [__] it's wrong it's
[__] up nah you're wrong Tim dude look
at his samurai sword shut up dude like
I'm not one of these uh like I'm not a
Zoomer so I I don't uh constantly talk
about like problematic age gaps like if
someone is 25 and the other person is 26
like what's going on there is there a
power imbalance like I'm not one of
those [__] weirdos right A lot of
people love uh uh having those arguments
but like pretty good rule to be like 18
and under you know don't touch that
that's weird it's gross it's illegal
[__] you all right let's see
people and criminals who are getting
away with everything that what we end up
seeing is law enforcement choose to go
after certain people when it benefits
them politically that's the nature of
the West today so when I see 20 year old
accusations it's Brett Kavanaugh all
over again this this idea that it's a
political hit job is just endlessly
funny to me this man gets 80 000 views
on Rumble he's he's the only thing he's
a threat to is like uh well he gets a
lot of views on uh on YouTube and now
more than before by the way because he's
been canceled yeah but that'll go back
down so
the thing is like are you are you
advocating to like
to not have to to have a statute of
limitations for like child endangerment
is that what's going on because that's
not very q and on of you my guy what's
happening you know
he's like oh the statute of limitation
is out the window he's actually about to
go much further than that he's like
listen if I can rape someone and get
away with it for 20 years that's it I
got away that's scot-free baby I made it
to the finish line
those are the rules those are the rules
you know what I'm saying
go on a raping spree as a young man
you'll be fine
yeah sorry don't care at all you want to
investigate you want to prove it by all
means please do so you prove it in a
court fine I get it but now does anyone
actually even believe these courts you
got Donald Trump living here you go
we don't believe the court we don't
believe in statute of limitations right
how are you existing in this world bro
isn't that crazy like usually the
conservative line or like the Russell
Brand Defenders it's like oh it's [__]
up that he's losing his uh YouTube
monetization before he goes to trial he
deserves a day in trial does that leave
him here is saying yeah even if he to
trial ends convicted I still don't
believe because we don't trust the
courts yeah we don't trust it doesn't it
doesn't even matter or again sorry don't
care at all you want to investigate you
want to prove it by all means please do
so you prove it in a court fine I get it
but now does anyone actually even
believe these courts is awesome you got
Donald Trump yeah yeah it doesn't even
matter he's innocent he created a a
perfect Loop where he's like
investigated in the courts if you if it
actually happened but also I I don't
even believe the court I don't believe
the courts so there's no way that you
can find Russell Brown uh Russell Brand
criminally liable and I refuse to read
the article I just won't read it
yeah I mean it's it's a it's a cool it's
a cool way to make like I guess a a
logically consistent article uh
logically consistent argument in your
own brain in your own like weird
logical Circle that you've closed in New
York I understand that he's just you
know
he's just appealing to his audience but
like just read it man I'm telling you
you'll be you're gonna be embarrassed if
you just read it
it's really bad dude he went to that
department store with Carol Eugene yeah
right what was the department store uh
recruitments right yeah Goodman's and
it's the busiest place with the most
famous man wait he's going back to Trump
assaulting this girl in a dressing room
as proof that Russell didn't do it yep
bro what are you doing and also like
again you're conflating this is a 20
year old accusation with Russell that
apparently just did this like four years
ago
no the all of the incidents were from
longer ago than that oh okay I think
what you're thinking of is a few years
ago is when uh behind the scenes it
started to come out and his co-star 20
years called him out and everything well
no I think it was not that it matters
just for the record it was like 10 to 12
years ago or so I'd like to talk to Tim
I've never talked to him because he is
just a [__] right I mean he really is
just dumb
um I think he's a he's a better
propagandist than uh we give him credit
uh I think that uh in a lot of instances
uh especially with Temple's uh situation
you're tailoring your message around the
audience's expectations needs and lack
of interest in like learning a different
side of the story uh an example I will
give you is this Kyle Kolinski yesterday
was making fun of the Trump fraud case
where uh a New York uh judge found that
Trump artificially inflated or
fraudulently inflated his assets by 2.6
billion dollars
his total assets were around 1 billion
he inflated that to 3.6 billion to get
more favorable loans from a bank this
was fraudulently done one aspect of that
was uh putting the price point of
Mar-A-Lago at 700 million dollars
mar-a-lago's actual price actual
valuation is 70 million dollars but if
you look at the surrounding region of
Mar-A-Lago there's a lot of small houses
on much smaller plots of land
that are worth 40 million 50 million
dollars so why is Mar-A-Lago only worth
70 million dollars this is very
confusing until you find out that there
is a land deed restriction that uh stops
appraisers from looking at Mar-A-Lago as
a uh as a residential real estate
property because you can never put
residential real estate on Mar-A-Lago
land this is something that Trump has
used
to to actually uh pay less taxes year
over year when he's talking to the IRS
right what did Tim say Tim
did the classic thing that conservatives
do and was like look at the houses
around you think Mar-A-Lago is only
worth 70 million dollars you're a
[__] idiot it's totally worth 700
million dollars I didn't say 1.5 billion
it was no no I'm saying like that's just
one of the many different properties
that he lied about like you think Trump
said mar-a-lago's worth 1.5 billion
um I don't know even more psychotic yeah
well
the point here is not necessarily Trump
lying about uh his his assets but more
so about Tim pool and others knowing
full well that uh if they investigated a
little bit further which I'm sure Tim
did uh they would find out that the the
land use uh restrictions on this deed
for Mar-A-Lago uh made it impossible for
Mar-A-Lago to be valued at 700 million
dollars and that's part of the reason
why the courts found it fraudulent
um but Tim knows they can just point to
like the dumbest thing that everyone
else around him that sounds normal and
sounds uh like a good argument if you
haven't investigated the situation
further so he'll just point to that and
move on with it this is what I'm saying
is like he's good at talking to his
people but like if you're in a debate
with somebody who's prepared and you say
that then it's like he he can't justify
his position I don't think it'd be easy
for him to do that which is why I think
it might be yeah but when you when you
do that so much when you do that so much
so frequently
um and the only types of debates you
have are in person in your own compound
because Tim Poole and I were supposed to
have time to his compound yeah simple
and I were supposed to have a talk
during covid
um and and and like he did this with Sam
Cedar as well where I was like yeah I'll
do it over Zoom like I don't want to go
to your place yeah you know I'm not
going to do that the [__] do you mean
why would I give you clout like that
like well who cares you don't need to
fly there to talk to him yeah and and
zoom was perfectly appropriate
appropriate he he does maintain the
position that I told him I would be down
to do it but only on Zoom
um and and he doesn't want that to
happen he wants you to be on his own
home turf uh uh like
and and I'm not interested in doing that
at all because I'm not going to take
time off uh just to go and talk to Tim
Poole but I'd be willing to talk about
why don't you come to my office [__]
ass coward I don't I don't think he
would do that well then why the [__]
should anyone go to his dog but I think
we could do it via Zoom I'm the bigger
dog Tim I got more views Mike I got more
crew members they're cool not even it's
not even about that well then what the
[__] is it about more so about having
you in a controlled environment where
you can get like multiple uh lines of
attack from different people like he did
this with Emma too that's true when I
sit at the table with him it's like a
six against one uh but I don't know if
we're cooler either to be honest I don't
own it I don't understand I don't have
an 18th century uh pirate pistol either
I do oh do you yeah I have well I'm cool
though I have an mk18 Daniel Defense I
have uh a Glock I have multiple katanas
wow I just think it's funny that he's
like Sam Cedar Hassan Pike or cowards
for not coming to the show it's like oh
do you want to come to my show I would
never do that
yeah it's it's very odd I mean I'm I'm
perfectly willing and able to talk to
Tim uh at any point in time uh as long
as it's on you know
conditions in terms that I'm comfortable
with I'm not going to like quit my
stream to go [__] fly to his compound
and hang out with the sweaty friends
like I don't want to do that his
audience doesn't care if it's on Zoom
everybody would watch that yeah 100
yeah and are arguably in the city nobody
owns the hotel next door he owns nobody
noticed Donald Trump with no security
going in the second floor I think it was
and and then and then a New York jury
finds Donald Trump accountable liable
for for this this assault or something
sexual assault this is why he believes
Russell Brand by the way this is him
this is me trying to get him to read the
article
you just won't look at it you just won't
look
read the article at least brother
Dane that's insane all right shut up
dummy
shut up that's Temple everybody we love
him
thank you
um
um we should probably skip ahead yeah
because uh so Trump organization you
touched on this but this is pretty spicy
actually this is like Mega spicy this is
like nuclear a New York judge ordered
the dissolution of whoops
of businesses owned by Donald Trump
and you did everything right he did
everything right and they're indicting
him again uh he's been found to have
committed fraud in terms of uh declaring
his net worth in uh loan documents which
is a big [__] crime that's a serious
[__] uh the judge found that Trump and
his company fraudulently missed the
value of their assets canceled any cert
and canceled their certificates for
business
as well as any entity owned by Trump
Eric Donald or Alan Weisberg or Trump
organization executive Jeffrey mcconney
that's a pretty serious dude the ruling
applies that Trump organization is no
longer recognized as a company company
in New York a court appointed individual
take over its assets and distribute them
as deemed appropriate dude that's crazy
that's crazy so what he's been doing
essentially is getting tons of loans
which billionaires do
the problem is he's puts down his uh his
assets and his collateral to guarantee
against the loan he's been saying the
Mar-A-Lago for example just one example
is worth 1.5 billion right I saw him
said it's 700 million but I thought it
was he said it was one point there were
two instances here I have uh I have
exactly where the judge breaks down what
they found
uh your highlighter for me here is this
one yeah so
so oh yeah here's the judge's um ruling
on the matter let's read this from 2011
to 2021 the Palm Beach County Assessor
appraised the market value of Mar-A-Lago
at between 18 million and 27 million
notwithstanding the F the sfc's value do
not reflect these lands use restrictions
it says it very clearly actually Donald
Trump's sfc values monologue between 400
million and 600 million an overvaluation
of two thousand three hundred percent
compared to the Assessor's appraisal the
best part is when he is actually like
the difference between him going to a
bank versus him going to the federal
government in the IRS and like showing
his properties is the exact opposite so
like he's undervaluing it every single
time he's talking to the government and
saying this is a depreciating asset look
I have land use restrictions and this is
like a piece of [__] right but when he
goes to the [__] when he goes to the
bank he's like like this isn't this is
the greatest [__] place of 2020
Donald Trump sued the the uh
municipality because they overvalued the
property because he wanted to pay less
property taxes yeah tax Representatives
act on behalf of trump filed a petition
this year to State authorized value a
judgment board challenging the
evaluation assign a mar-a-log on the
Trump National Golf Club and Jupiter
according to spokesman uh the petition
for Jupiter property was subsequently
withdrawn said agency spokesman a
virtual hearing has been scheduled for
December 3rd because their mar-a-lago's
valuation which at 2.6 million is
unchanged from last year
no 26 million 26 million yeah it's not
2.6 million so so
um but here it says also the judge wrote
critically uh moans does not owe Pine at
what price he is confident he could find
a buyer although he opened separately
without relying on any objective
evidence that he believes that as of
2023 the property is worth 1.5 billion
that's awesome
so
um a couple things that to note here I
think one of the scariest and most
insane things that Trump actually
dropped in the deposition that
suspiciously is not getting a lot of
media coverage is that he said he
basically has an unlimited line of
credit from Saudi Arabia that he could
just sell
yes that's what the that's what a
footnote uh that's what the judge says
he said in the deposition I haven't seen
it but oh yeah definitely trust the
judge if he that he's well he basically
says I can sell my properties for you
know 10x 20x whatever the [__] I want to
Saudi Arabia at any given moment which
technically Isn't false he is right
about that Saudi Arabia did give Jared
Kushner Donald Trump's uh son-in-law two
billion dollars in the uh Sovereign
wealth fund uh for Jared kushner's new
Venture uh and that obviously came with
uh you know that didn't come for free
that like they didn't do that out of the
kindness of their hearts or think they
didn't do that because they think Jared
Kushner is like an incredible [__]
investor they did it because they like
having an inside guy they like having
control over uh it's exactly what uh
they accuse Hunter Biden of doing
frankly yes except it's what Hunter did
is even less direct yes because
serving as his advisor unlike Jared
Kushner 100 Biden Hunter Biden never had
like he never had any [__] Sway in
the Obama Administration nor the the
Biden was a he's an official advisor he
has security clearance for a while yes
he was he did the [__] uh like he
facilitated the the Abraham Accords he
was Mr Israel peace yeah so yeah he was
put in a incredible position of Power
with no [__] background that's sick
now that's a bribe and he [__] I
gotta say it to his credit I see people
getting bribed and it's always too
little money like the [__] the [__]
the demon Menendez what I mean he got a
couple gold bars paid but like Jared he
got 1.5 yeah he made out like a [__]
deprived two two Billy 2.5 Billy no just
I think two billion two billion and
Saudi Arabia MBS recently because he's
doing the the
he's doing his charm offensive again
because like enough time has passed
since the German [__] so like uh you
know he's back on U.S soil talking about
like you know the golf courses and how
awesome it is he gave an English
interview to Fox News this past week
where where in the interview who
basically said uh yeah we gave 2 billion
to Jared Kushner and you know we'll
probably give him more and that uh he
loves the idea of another Trump
presidency nice
um well anyway according to um
according to the documents reporting he
apparently overstated his Worth to at in
assets to Banks and insurers by as much
as 3.6 billion
did you see the Saudi Arabian line in
the deposition
that they just pulled up here there it
is
but in a deposition Trump seems to imply
that the numbers cannot be inflated
because he could find a buyer from Saudi
Arabia to pay any price He suggests New
York state supreme court judge Arthur
engeron wrote in his ruling despite the
uh disturbing uh
suggestion that is that's not how
um evaluations were that's just not how
you're like no trust me
I could find him I know a guy I know a
guy that's not how it works you know and
I mean obviously there is uh you know
the market on top like uh Eric Trump uh
and we have that in the dock here at
number six was uh trying to argue it's
ridiculous that the judge was saying
it's worth uh 26 million or whatever
because look at how expensive all these
other properties in Florida are exactly
because he says 130 at this size so what
he's saying is these are their property
is worth 30 times whatever yeah no but
he's he's right uh and he's wrong he's
right that the properties next to
Mar-A-Lago are residential real estate
properties that are going for that uh
that amount right it is to show the the
market consideration for real estate in
that area but those are Residential
Properties while they are tiny in
comparison to the massive plot of land
that Mar-A-Lago sits on they do not have
land use restrictions that's
specifically detail that you cannot use
Mar-A-Lago as a residential real estate
you cannot chop up Mar-A-Lago land to
turn it into residential real estate so
you can't do that which the trumpet the
Trump organization knew and as you also
correctly showed has used to their
advantage year over year in an effort to
pay less taxes or actually show
Mar-A-Lago as a depreciating asset so
that they can cut taxes in general yeah
we knew about all of this because Donald
Trump literally not the not the uh the
the overvaluation of his properties but
we knew about Donald Trump undervaluing
his properties and showing them his
depreciating assets just in 2020 he was
arguing that it's they overvaluated
because because of the whole Trump tax
return [__] remember when we were
talking about how like Trump paid 75 000
in tax and we're like what the [__] is
that about yeah yeah that was because of
this because he was openly stating that
his uh land use restrictions were making
was making Mar-A-Lago a depreciating
asset the the brazenness like if I I
feel like if I tried that [__] on my
taxes I would get [__] immediately
yeah you got to cut the candles
I worked with would be like that's
[__] insane I'd be arrested if I
signed off on this well yeah you could
do the Trump thing and like go
accountant shopping until like the one
accountant will say oh yeah no we can do
that yeah
I guess we'll find a way but I'm trying
to let's see how much of the property is
unusable
um from Air you know I mean like how
much of it is just totally un it's like
it's like a country club essentially
yeah so like there's like uh it's kind
of a hotel in there and stuff and like
nice spot though oh this is the whole
area this is his plot yeah yeah which
when you look at it this is all unused
yeah and you cannot turn that into
residential real estate right you can't
do that you can't build on it you cannot
sell or use this land for any commercial
purpose therefore it doesn't get you
know for any residential purpose yes
it's commercial real estate the reason
why it's only valued at 70 million in
comparison to like all the other
properties is because those other
properties are houses right a house says
upkeep especially once as large as that
one uh in that area but like Mar-A-Lago
and the upkeep required for it is a an
insane amount so obviously that's the
reason why there's a there's a
limitation to how much you can uh how
how expensive you can claim this thing
is and how valuable this is Sam he owns
this because that [__] looks nice look
I've never been to the term what is this
Palm Beach Palm Beach you know is that
what it's all like just the students
[__] I think really it's one of those
places where it's like yeah I mean it
looks like it's going to be underwater
and like oh that's no question about it
in like 10 years it's probably hurting
the property value too bro look it looks
like it's under sea level like this
looks like a sea wall
yeah that's true I mean how much is that
[__] worth it's not going to exist in 10
years probably enjoy it while you've got
a narrow strip of land okay well there
he is so Trump is getting absolutely
[__] dude by uh New York State I did
everything right and then I don't know
what to say I mean the guy committed
fraud on a massive scale what do you
want the craziest part about this too is
that um this was all over a Civil Trial
he was being sued
um by uh what's it called the
not district attorney was this attorney
general thing huh was this a discovery
thing
well it's not just that it's it's the
fact that it this was supposed to go to
trial like next week and the judge after
looking over the evidence just thought
it was so egregious that
they were willing to dissolve his
business before even going to trial like
that's how like on its face obvious it
was that he was doing this fraud yeah
there's like there's different uh types
of fraud aside from like obviously hyper
inflating the value of your of your
assets but like he lied about the square
footage that's so stupid yeah like
that's that's so measurable
how do you lie about that I mean yeah I
guess he lies about his height so that's
even more measurable yeah it's just you
can get away with it right I mean yes so
the interesting part of this is to see
which banks and loaning institutions are
going to sue him for fraud that's going
to be real fun to follow I mean it
entirely depends on whether or not he
becomes president because if he becomes
president he's going to give them
favorable uh deregulation so they will
not do that and they love that and
um so you know we'll see we'll see which
way which way this goes like a lot of
this okay I have two conflicting
thoughts on this on the one hand
when Trump says like what I've done is
not out of the ordinary he's not wrong
okay real estate and the way that uh the
the real estate industry works is
this is all
not necessarily legally permissible but
things that a lot of people do all the
time and completely Overlook lie about
their assets yeah depreciating yeah
depreciating the value of your uh
depreciating like showing your assets as
depreciating Assets in an effort to get
uh in an effort to significantly cut
your tax burden while simultaneously
showing it as as much as you can that is
common but like lying to Lone
institutions about the value of your of
your assets that seems crazy I think
not for the degree that Trump did it but
I think yeah and not with like you know
lying about your square footage and
whatnot but yeah I think people do it
people probably people definitely
there's a difference between fun a
little bit right fudging which is
not what he did yeah not 2 300. this is
like that's insane definitely yeah
that's crazy
um all right well let's move on we don't
have a lot of we have about 30 minutes
so let's keep it moving right you got
something else you wanted to close it
out on there's a lot of stuff that we
can talk about I don't care I want to
talk about the baby we can talk about uh
the UAW Auto strike that's going on we
talk about a lot let's talk about the
debate as in let me look at the title
those two kind of flow into each other
because of the uh Trump connection
anyways so those two the debate which
again Trump wasn't at he won he won that
debate last night well what's
interesting that all The Debaters
are lower
and pulling than the they're all just
they're being worse they're just losing
by being there yeah
yeah they look uh unserious they look
pathetic they look terrible uh overall I
think like Nikki Haley maybe uh uh in my
opinion did you watch it I watched clips
of it I heard people like that she did
well yeah Nikki Haley does a decent job
it's very interesting though because
like every time she speaks out against
Trump
it's almost in a way where like Joe
Biden can use that against Trump as well
because like it's always like you know
how much Trump imploded the deficit
right like things of that nature
um but I think she is probably the
smartest old school Republican that is
like uh clear with her message
still ruthless still brutal still awful
but uh in comparison to the rest of
those [__] losers like she comes out
uh she comes across as like at least a
relatively intelligent she went after a
boy Vivek Viva Vivek oh yeah Vivek had I
think like cake the biggest uh else
that's good I'm glad to hear that
because he's so tired of that guy and
please come on our show
um no he goes to this yeah Vivek and
Rhonda Santos are in the same camp where
the more they talk the more people go oh
you're gross and I don't like you and
obviously politics is a lot I mean
politics for the most part in America
especially now is like very Vibes based
right and if you are coming across like
a smarmy annoying debate pervert who's
constantly going ah actually uh the
Constitution says I could do this like
then you know it worked the first time
television Watcher no it actually didn't
people loved him no he he saw a little
bit of a boost initial because he was
like riding Trump's dick so [__] hard
he was doing tricks on he was blowing
bubbles on that [__] but then eventually
the more he like had to defend himself
in a defensive posture in major media
the more his uh approval rating started
plummeting
um after the debate I saw a lot of
people being like this guy's full of
[__] but anyway here's how the debate
started let's take a look
sitting alongside My co-moderators Fox
News Channel Dana Perino and Ilya
Calderon do they call their own as my
code
I think he surprised himself that he got
the pronunciation correct yeah he hit
that Calderon yeah and then he would
like kind of stumbled after that [__] I
nailed that smooth man smooth sailing
Univision dude that was wrong that was
rough he made it he stuck the landing he
stuck the landing
I mean it could have been worse you
remember Jesse Wellen
oh my God I haven't thought of that in
so long remember that song Wait what
happened you remember Jesse
wellsy Wellens at the game it was uh E3
yeah E3 yo this is all right I gotta go
back and enjoy this real fast this is
bad
that was a good year for Content I feel
like
what up guys
if you guys don't know who I am my name
is Jesse Wellens and I am a YouTube
Creator so I am here
to talk about Need for Speed
um Payback
uh if you guys didn't know Need for
Speed Payback
I'm
um oh no
[Music]
yeah it's great game but all right all
set aside bro people from Philadelphia
can't read the [__] out I got my boys
Marcus executive producer here I believe
this firmly now thank you for having me
hey man thanks Jesse um obviously we're
really excited to tell everyone about
I love that he is so aware that he
[__] up Yeah we actually had him call
in it was pretty funny he said no he
came in in person yeah we talked about
it at length how embarrassing it was for
him he said um the teleprompter was off
and the cue to turn around was off yeah
there were some production issues it
wasn't totally his fault but OG
prankster yeah yeah shout out Prank
versus Frank yeah you know he'd live
with uh I think he lived with Andy
Milonakis for a while yeah yeah I
remember hanging out with them uh way
back in the day
like randomly so let's see um yada yada
Chris Christie our boy
back from the buffet for this epic thing
that's that and that's that's not mine
that's my that's his words
whose words trumps trumps
I won't and I won't I won't
oh so here we go tell me what you think
about it look at this camera right now I
can tell you Donald I know you're
watching you can't help yourself I know
you're watching okay and you're not here
tonight not because of polls and not
because of your indictments you're not
here tonight because you're afraid of
being on the stage and Defending Your
record you're ducking these things and
let me tell you what's going to happen
you keep doing that no one up here is
going to call you Donald Trump anymore
we're gonna call you Donald Duck
this name thing gone too far definitely
Donald Duck
bro that that oh God oh my God if I was
ever ashamed to have been from New
Jersey at any point in my life this is
the worst op this is the worst time you
kind of Hit the uh the Kevin James smirk
at the end there you know his ass crack
is that in front of a mirror okay yeah
was like he probably spent a hundred
thousand dollars like in marketing uh
gurus to cut to yeah
ducking these things and let me tell you
what's going to happen you keep doing
that look at that Kevin James face
no they're a little bit longer writers
and ride right after he hits him Trump
anymore we're gonna call you Donald Duck
oh that's good
got him that's that Christy face dude
like I I like the in theory but calling
someone Donald Duck is just
well Trump literally said or he'll just
tell him to kill himself
because Christy should be executed he
basically did he responded on true
social he says something along the lines
of like I I'm pretty sure he says
something like uh shut the [__] up you
had five percent approval rating like
when you by the time you left office
like what the [__] are you talking about
idiot send that I want to read that but
in the meantime this needs to be a new
chat Emoji oh that's pretty good that's
a good ass face right there boy you know
so um
[Laughter]
yeah Porky Pig That's all folks that's
all Christy
thanks no no not that one Zach that
one's a classic though I know I just I
just I just yet Roy Rogers at 11 p.m
it's just the greatest thing I've ever
seen in my life yeah it's one of the
best you know what I have to say this
photo is pretty incredible there's
nobody else in it
it is late and he is the only one there
yeah trying to console himself look at
his head like he's his head sunken in a
fat pig
oh God he is such a demon it's crazy
because uh I talked about this last
night
um big boys are are doing really well in
the polls like big boys across the board
from John fetterman JB pritzker you know
yeah it's big boy season and and yet
Chris Christie has not seen
Chris Christie has not seen a single
piece of that big boy action because
he's so pathetically unlikable and is
basically running in the Democratic
primary
while while actually running in the
Republican primary like all of the
messaging
all the messaging he engages with is
like are you trying to be the [__]
Democratic president like what's
happening he only goes on CNN he only
goes on MSNBC he's just trying to get
the liberal vote for some weird reason I
don't know why I guess he's just trying
to get a CNN he just yeah he just wants
clout yeah I mean it's probably going to
translate to a lot of money for him in
terms of whatever book deals show deals
I don't know I'm trying to find that uh
Trump response to this but truth social
is seemingly down right now so I don't
know
how can this happen oh wait it finally
loaded I kept refreshing and it popped
up I'll try and find his tweet anyway
meanwhile uh um yeah it's on the hill if
you wanna
the hill okay yeah while you look for
that here's um the santis saying Donald
Trump owes it to you to defend his
record where they added 7.8 trillion to
the debt that set the stage for the
inflation that we have now Joe Biden uh
responded
Donald Trump is missing in action he
should be on this stage tonight he owes
it to you
defend his record where they added 7.8
.8 trillion to the dead oh yeah it's
smart he said do you share the same this
day that I do for California Republicans
like the most annoying in my opinion
like one of the more annoying type of
Republicans like I'll talk to a [__]
racist ass Alabama Republican all day
every day because like I get where
they're coming from but like the
California Republicans irk me who are
you talking about the people that are in
that room right now because this is in
Simi Valley at the Ronald Reagan Library
and it's obviously I don't know a lot of
them but I know they're all California
Republicans in there who [__] want
California to be Florida so bad it's
like just move the [__] Florida
[__] well I know that when I go to
like Orange County I just see a bunch of
Mega boaters but
I guess yeah I see why they wanted to be
Florida they already live in like the
most Florida part of California I just I
hate them so much I have so much I have
so much passion in my heart for for
California Republicans like all four
million numbers yeah we do with them
we should send them to Florida I have
talked about this so many times before
someone I train to Florida yes bro put
him on a [__] train to Florida okay
trail of put them on put him on yeah no
take all their assets they can live in a
Libertarian Utopia build a wall around
Florida and routinely fly in there and
extract babies out of Florida to make
sure that they are not suffering the
consequence of living in this [__]
libertarian and cap dystopia in Florida
all aboard it's gonna sink anyway
speaking of and cap dystopia whatever
happened remember one of the First
episodes of leftovers we talked about
um Glenn Beck starting like his own like
little Nation you remember what I'm
talking about starting I don't even
remember that was like looking
it was like uh what's the what's the
Utopia from uh Atlas Shrugged uh
you fly into it it's like wakanda yeah
um so let's see what else we got here
thank you to uh president Joel Biden
wake up
uh here is Nikki slamming uh Vivek
and it's pretty
it's pretty like
I I don't know I feel like if I was in a
debate or argument if I said this I I
wouldn't say this but I guess it doesn't
really matter I mean this came off to me
it's like whoa chill but listen this is
what you're about the show is Daisy on
Desi violence and I'm gonna tell you
something it was I was here for it Nikki
Haley popped the [__] off
I just I would think that I guess it's a
different breed I feel like if I said
something like this people were like
whoa dude
every time I hear you yeah they would be
like ad hominem which is I'm shocked
that Vivek who is such a petulant little
child and like such a smarmy little
debate Lord he didn't hit that Ah that's
actually an ad hominem at-home
moderators but it is it is a smart disc
because I feel like his whole thing is
like I'm the smart guy nobody can say
I'm not a genius that's what everyone
says about him right so she comes right
for that there's one person
infuriating because Tick Tock is one of
the most dangerous social media apps
that we could have agreed right what
you've got honestly every time I hear
you I feel a little bit Dumber for what
you say damn bro
she hit it in such a way that
bro he's he's look at him he's pride is
demolished yeah
yeah like that that that cut for some
reason just wait on that didn't come
across it was just yeah and the thing
was like people weren't like booing her
they were like yeah you're kind of right
like yeah he is pretty annoying isn't it
yeah he got [__] on honestly every
time I hear you I feel a little bit
Dumber for what you say because I can't
believe they hear me Tick-Tock situation
I don't know what they're doing by the
way can I say Vivek looks like butthead
his hair is getting taller every time I
don't know what's happening there wait
Beavis or butthole no butt head side by
side of butt head and and Vivek they
have the same like I thought about that
but I kind of immediately know what you
mean they've got the Dome shape
I don't know he needs a Beavis
Mike Pence nah yeah that's that's him
I can see it I said the Energy's there a
little bit thank you thank you
thank you so much
but yeah
um here the the most accurate
summarization of last night's
Shenanigans was uh who's gonna invade
Mexico harder who's going to put a bomb
in the Department of Education harder
like uh who's gonna nuke it you know
what I mean that's what they they were
like stepping over one another Mike
Pence came out of the gate swinging on
abortion again because he's a actual
psychopath like I think Mike Pence is
one of those like honest sociopaths like
honest to God like they lit abortion is
the hardest and yet most important point
of contention here in the Republican
primaries and it's going to in my
opinion
basically make or break the general
unless the Democrats somehow find a way
to [__] that up too which you know they
might
um it's a massive erosion of civil
liberties Republican women hate it
Republicans don't even like that this is
happening it is deeply unpopular in deep
red areas and deep red States anytime
it's on a ballot uh you end up uh
allowing Democrats to win by like you
know like reverse Ronald Reagan margins
you know what I mean like it's crazy
um and that's precisely the reason why
on the Republican primary debate they
put it at the tail end of the commentary
the tail end of the broadcast so that
you know less people pay attention to it
um they asked the abortion conversation
the question to like two people and then
they redirected the conversation to Mike
Pence where they at the Univision lady
asked them like what do you what will
you do to earn the Latino Vote or
something right and Mike Pence was like
instead of taking this gracefully and
going oh thank you for allowing me not
to talk about abortion because I'm a
psychopathic freak took that answer and
redirected it back to abortion to be
like no we're doing a federal ban which
is insane because it's so incredibly
unpopular
Mike Pence is like he's truly one of
these like uh husbands from the Gilead
from handsome handmade instead yeah yeah
no he wants like you know
he wants like breathable he treats women
like cows
baby incubators here's to Santa's
answering the abortion question
could come down
50 000 votes in three states abortion
was on the ballot in six days in 2022
Republican
and yeah bro can you like stop making
that thing
you can't stop please stop bro his
advisor is like bro please work on this
face look at you man he was there were
so many weird ones last night too
oh dude he's awesome next year abortion
will likely be on the ballot what why
did he do that he did the weird liquor
thing weird
abortion will likely be on the back what
ozempic phase dude oh when the Olympic
hits
that's something else man something else
in Arizona that is a must-win state
how are you going to this election could
come oh that was it just how [__]
weird he is yeah nice how are you gonna
win Arizona ah I'm pro-life it's like
you're so [__] dog and you deserve it
you deserve to be [__] the Republican
Party deserves everything that that's
coming for them
oh God I I just it's it's deeply
frustrating to see them uh in this bind
and and not necessarily any like clear
uh way out of this bind because they are
suffering from success
just like Khalid
um people is this is the one with the
last thing I want to show okay so
DeSantis and Gavin Newsom are going to
be having a debate for some reason now
I'm looking forward to this because say
what you about Gavin but he's very smart
and he's very well spoken he's going to
decimate DeSantis I think so too
spectacular he can't do any pushback
like he's really [__] bad at at uh
the debate stage or even appearing like
he's a human seems like he gets too mad
he gets like triggered yeah he's ironic
because they're always like worst on a
debate to get angry right but like he's
doing Gavin the fattest favor because
like Gavin's just getting more and more
media attention he's gonna look like a
genius slick politician extraordinaire
next to DeSantis and um listen here's
what he had to say about DeSantis
agreeing to apparently the Santa's even
been talking talking boy alex he's
spending money promoting
this this debate they're having listen
between you and Ron DeSantis November
30th Fox News Channel Sean Hannity in
Georgia without a crowd uh just the two
of you God he's got beautiful hair man I
can't deny it he does he's sorry he's so
[__] hot dude you know he's got the
voice he's got the posture he's got his
hair I just wish he wasn't such a
[__] neoliberal demon you know what I
mean he's like the governor of the The
Bluest of states
uh with a 80 billion dollar budget
surplus and like
um as as uh I'm gonna [__] his name up
Eddie Edinger mentem last night
adequately put he is to the right of the
State Legislature
which is insane like the California
state legislature is literally more
Progressive even though they are also
they could be significantly more
Progressive as well and like gruesome
Governor Gavin Newsom is is is the most
annoying type of uh neoliberal
well
but did you see his hair bro I mean yeah
he's hot he's hot he's hot no arguing
there I I agree with that that's like
perfect care man I mean get out of here
dude that's how we got Kimberly
Guilfoyle he's going to be president he
will be no he won't with that hair he's
going to be president no he won't big
Gretch big Gretch JB pritzker there are
significantly better Governors out there
and he's good I'm saying he's going to
be president no I'm not saying I think I
think the the the problem with Newsome
is that he's a Democrat from California
yeah until a lot of the country is a
problem you know what I mean here's here
there's two different reasons there's
the fake reason there's the fake reason
why he will never be president and then
there's the real reason fake reason
being that everybody thinks California
is a criminal [__] and like it has
like insane crimes happening all the
[__] time because mainstream media
constantly pumps that narrative despite
the fact that California's violent crime
uh uh rates are are lower than the
national average gun violence lower than
national average
um and and crime in general is is not on
the rise in California in comparison to
other states red states are
significantly worse on violent crimes
especially gun violence
um like not even a comparison okay New
York and California have lower crime
rates than South Carolina and Florida
suck my dick everyone who [__]
constantly cries about crime in
California so that's number one number
two that's the fake reason as to why he
won't be able to uh you know make gains
no matter how uh
no matter how well he is perceived the
real reason is homelessness
homelessness is a gigantic issue in the
state of California once again a state
with 80 million 80 billion dollars of
budget surplus a state that literally
has launched initiatives time and time
again ballot measures time and time
again that we voted on to ensure that we
fill the coffers with adequate funding
to create initiatives that are housing
first policies and yet he is so deeply
uh in the pocket of real estate
developers and homeowners associations
uh in this in the state that he uh
doesn't fight hard enough to solve the
homelessness problem and that's a very
real problem that uh you will you can
cut a thousand hours of propaganda off
of if you were to ever run for president
don't turn everywhere into Skid Row is
what they would say that's pretty good
yeah that's why most uh
National Democrats uh I guess not most
anymore but oftentimes are from more
conservative States like Bill Clinton is
like the classic example from Arkansas
you know what I mean it's like that it
softens the blow of being a lib a little
bit yeah do that but anyway here he is
just really dunking on desantis's dumb
ass here doing that and what is your
strategy and it's I don't know if that's
the right question why is he doing it
this is the right question he's running
I think I'm not sure after tonight but
currently he's running for president
United States
um
do you think he'll still be a candidate
on November 30th that's an open any
question part of me wonders if you know
the fact that he took this debate the
fact that he took the bait in his
relationship this debate shows that he's
completely unqualified to be president
United States that's been humble foreign
to promote a debate against the governor
dude he ran this ad and I guess it's too
late to back out look at that they gosh
I don't think that
um that gruesome is right I think that
Rhonda Sanders is doing this because
like the the American at least in the
hearts and minds of like the voters that
matter
right people that are living in the
suburbs which can go in either direction
right now the reality is that the the
point of contention exists between
California liberals and California
moderates versus Florida Republicans and
Florida uh moderates it's it's the idea
that like do we want an
anarcho-capitalist dystopia like we do
in FL in Florida where uh you know it's
just like the state is sinking or do we
want uh a a supposedly communist but
actually just like a neoliberal uh
Aesthetics focused I think it will help
us potentially in his campaign what if
he does you think it might help his
campaign
um yeah I think so if he if he did well
but he's not going to so it's not going
to help him at all it's going to look
horrible it's going to be great for
Newsome I think that's the only outcome
I'm gonna watch this [__] though they're
gonna get the ratings boy oh yeah I will
watch them Sean loves Gavin Newsom he
does he does oh he thinks Gavin Newsom
is hot Johnny boy he does go on Hannity
a lot which is interesting yeah in fact
he was in Hannity was interviewing last
night after the debate oh this is going
to be phenomenal this is this is
fireworks yeah I think he's a Loki Stan
I think he should stick to [__] being
the governor of a massive state that is
like the economy like the 14th largest
economy on the planet and [__] do his
goddamn job and actually fix
homelessness he can do a debate on
pre-appropriate let him have of his fun
but the point is he doesn't give a [__]
like and there's no alternative because
there's a deep blue state so there's no
genuine primary opposition there's no
interest there's not enough money these
are like New York and California are are
like the the headquarters of
institutional Democratic power which is
sad because these are the states where
we could be making genuine gains in the
right direction to show the rest of the
country that we do have a a method of uh
a successful method of moving away from
the insane late stage capitalist uh hell
hole I mean we are doing more than other
states but I hope that we can do even
more than that you know like something
as simple as like uh guaranteed
maternity leave is something California
just uh enshrined in law which nobody
else has done yeah there's stuff like
that which I of course always appreciate
yeah and have some new gun laws uh last
week too didn't they I didn't I don't
recall that yeah we're our gun laws are
are sometimes a little crazy and silly
but sometimes they're silly but I mean
uh but oftentimes it's like very
productive and healthy and have uh kept
our our gun violence uh much lower more
than the national average which is a
good thing yeah
um but on the front of like uh you know
offering material benefits to uh the
Working Poor in the state we are
horrible that's a far cry from like
housing people which is what I think
we'd all like to see happen yeah because
nobody wants people to [__] live on
the streets okay I don't want that like
what the [__] nobody wants that that's
insane and it's it's weird that like we
just have to act like that's not a thing
that's happening all the time and
there's only two ways out of that you
either like continue applying pressure
to homeless people and like brutally
suppress them kill them uh you know draw
them push them into camps uh outside of
the the city borders like Rick Caruso
was suggesting
um or you house them and start the the
process of of you know healing these
people that have withstood a tremendous
amount of trauma doesn't seemed that
hard I feel like you can make like so
many of these little but the housing
market Ethan is usually it wouldn't even
be I feel like I wouldn't even
participate you're not how like you're
making these little like
not even it's like half a studio but
it's got all you need it's got like the
AC reappropriating uh hotels with
reprobing things I know that's that's
actually uh one of the many initiatives
uh the the uh project room key is what
it's called
um yeah it's a great idea except the
[__] Chamber of Commerce despises it
because they think like uh they think
that no Hotel will ever recover from
this
um we rarely ever utilize eminent domain
it's very frustrating uh we there is a
you know there there are so many hurdles
in front of projects like that and
especially we have the money to be like
we do I'm saying I don't think it's that
expensive to build like a tiny little
Abode like the bare minimum necessity so
that you're not dying and stuff the
California economy does not have a money
problem at this point yeah that's what
I'm saying no we have a we have we could
probably build one of those for like ten
thousand dollars maybe even less bro
we've literally put billions of dollars
aside that people have voted on okay to
specifically Implement these initiatives
the problem is the money gets put in a
[__] uh the money gets the the money
gets put in a wallet and it just sits
there because you can't even launch
these initiatives because every single
time you try to like build even a
homeless shelter which is like an
inadequate solution to begin with right
it's not even a good solution it's
demonstrably a failure in America even
then people lose their [__] minds you
do these like it look to any do you want
to live next to a homeless shelter
that's what you always hear yeah and and
for me the alternative is like it's
better it's still better than [__]
having uh dudes live outside of your
house and like [__] on your [__]
front yard like what are you talking
about it's like so cruel and like
there's that's how all real estate is
there's some places that are more
desirable than others and uh you know
you can move
you don't like it that's oftentimes what
it comes down to is like
local community groups protesting it
saying no we don't want this I feel like
you could get like everybody wants the
shelter but nobody wants to live near it
there's there's got to be like
a huge plot of land somewhere on the
outskirts of Los Angeles
but I don't know if people would want to
live that far I don't know how that
works either no that's not that's not
how you solve this anyway because
there's always new people becoming
homeless because people don't become
homeless because you have like an office
or a program where people can say hey I
don't have a place to live and then you
take them yes a place where they have a
shelter social have to be in the heart
of the city but there's also the other
side of the issue which is something
that people always forget
that's not there's there's two different
problems here with homelessness okay on
the one hand you have the existing
homeless person on the street how do we
solve that problem how do we heal how do
we help that person on the other side
you have people that are also becoming
homeless right now
both of these problems can be solved by
decommodifying housing okay taking the
necessary initiatives to make it as
expensive as possible as humanly
possible to be a landlord and to own
multiple uh uh multiple residential real
estate properties
um
and and uh providing adequate social
housing as well because you need to make
sure that people aren't getting priced
out of the housing market so that there
aren't new homeless people every day
that are becoming homeless and living on
the streets so we're not doing any of
that though I agree that's we're not
doing that and that and that requires
you to build new units and not new units
specifically uh like as as luxury uh
condominiums that are going to sit empty
for [__] uh a decade you know what I
mean while you wait for uh some Saudi
Sovereign investment fund to come in and
purchase the rest of the units right uh
I mean like immediately build social
housing we have the money but that would
the press the housing market in
California and see how this this is what
do you mean these are not people who are
buying property these are people who
can't afford a place to live it
depresses it because now you have an
alternative
you have an alternative I don't think
people are going to be like I don't I
want to live in public housing instead
of like an apartment because
I if they have the means I don't see
that happening a lot no it's well it's
scarcity scarcity is part of the reason
why uh the the housing market is the way
it is in Los Angeles and in these uh big
uh real estate uh markets yeah scarcity
Airbnb for example is yet another reason
as to why there's more scarcity because
it's not being used as long-term viable
real estate that you know houses
families it's now being used as a
substitute for hotels so now
um you have scarcity because there's
only a limited amount of land and
utilizing the land in a specific way or
at least zoning restrictions that
they've created in these uh real estate
markets is one of the many different
reasons as to why this situation is
completely uh unmanageable uh I'm not uh
like uh one of those EMB uh weirdos
who's like like I'm not I debated Larry
Elder on this issue literally and he is
like a Libertarian yimby who wants to
just like keep pumping uh Investments
and keep building uh new housing uh and
new developments all around Los Angeles
but the right way to do that is by
making sure that we have mixed income
uh mixed income housing that can handle
the density of the population
we have zoning restrictions uh single
family for sure the zoning restriction
in LA are nuts yeah that that make it uh
impossible to like to overcome people
there's like a couple square miles where
you can build tall buildings yeah for
for residential but yeah I mean listen
on both ends it's crazy I mean the
the fact that
giant investment firms can buy up 30 of
all houses on the market which is what
was happening a few years ago with like
BlackRock
um is is can we just nuts can we just
say you can't do that anymore I think
does that just seem like obvious to
everyone or at least like like I almost
feel like that should be bipartisan like
obviously not developers and like people
that directly benefit from this but I
feel like you could even easily get
Republican voters on board with like hey
BlackRock shouldn't own 30 of your town
because and it's like it just seems so
like obvious well and it's like who this
is benefiting like five dudes who like
own BlackRock against the the interest
of like whatever 10 million people that
live in Los Angeles I think is more
complicated than that I think that
um the the the reality of the situation
is that
there are a in the United States of
America housing is seen as the most
viable way to develop uh generational
wealth okay okay yeah and it is to a
certain degree true this is why
redlining was so uh significantly
discriminatory towards black people in
uh the Jim Crow north for example
and the problem is because of that a lot
of middle class Working Poor or uh upper
middle class individuals who have their
houses for Generations now
um due to uh prior policy initiatives
that that were very helpful in home
ownership and and boosting home
ownership
um a lot of people do have a vested
interest in maintaining their housing
values so the people that do actually go
out to vote those who have more Capital
than the prior generation or other than
the upcoming generation they are the
ones who do check the housing market the
real estate market pretty regularly
because that because BlackRock is buying
every house on the market their property
value goes up well because it's not just
BlackRock I'm saying that like no this
would genuinely
uh this would genuinely to like take
take a chunk of the net worth from not
just BlackRock obviously but like
legitimate single-family uh house owners
I'm not opposed to people having like
two houses like in the situation where
you're like we have this house no no I'm
gonna talk about that I'm talking about
people who own one house
I don't see why I wouldn't necessarily
devalue it it well if there's more if
there's more Supply
we're just talking about saying
BlackRock you can't own 30 of the houses
in La that that won't that won't
legitimately I don't it'll put a dent
it's like Airbnb that's a good
initiative the black Arc thing you're
suggesting good initiative but
um but all of this is still working to
boost uh the the
prices of the available inventory of
houses which many people have taken
loans against many people taking
mortgages against yeah right so like if
their value if they're valued declines
all of a sudden they're in a tricky
financial situation that will cause them
to have a reactionary pushback I can see
why Mass public housing could reduce the
value but I don't understand delimiting
how much houses somebody can own reduces
the value of the properties oh just as
far as uh well because a lot of those
houses sit empty right
it's not necessarily that BlackRock owns
a shitload of houses is that they just
buy up a bunch of houses and let them
sit and appreciate in value so that they
can flip them for a profit after a while
so it's just right it's just that they
own it's that they're using they drive
the price they're playing the realest in
market for a profit right and like and
like Hassan said earlier it's it's about
long-term decommodifying shelter because
yeah I wonder if there's a way for that
we shouldn't necessarily let these
people be doing this with this fight I
don't know like well I don't think
healthier is the only thing that is
susceptible to the the market forces of
of being in a an inelastic uh demand
good I think housing should be
categorized under a similar uh in a
similar fashion you know when they
shelter you die you have to get shelter
when you do gun bans you buy the guns
from the people I wonder if there's a
way to compensate
single families who are right and that
is so hard to see movement on this
because it is like the domino effect of
all of these things is there's got to be
a way to I I just I'm fully cognizant of
how difficult of an Endeavor this is is
why I always go back to like talking
about the average voter that owns like
like the average voter
Chatters that are watching right now
they're parents let's say who've had
their house since like the 60s 70s that
they're sitting on that property value
has skyrocketed over the course of those
years you might even have paid off all
of your uh you know you might own the
house fully and then maybe you took out
a a mortgage on it right it's got a loan
against your house if the value of that
diminishes all of a sudden your net
worth is going down so now you feel like
your nest egg is actually uh in a in a
perilous situation you're you're going
to react to that you're not going to
want that to happen which is why like it
is somewhat authoritarian my my uh
assessment of the situation is like
build more housing don't [__] tell
the public just do it you know
ironically uh Chinese Communist party
style just like build housing and be
like no oh we just built it here shut
the [__] up well another thing you could
do is like starting now you can't do it
anymore
yeah don't you don't do it retroactive
you're just like starting now you can't
anyone who already owns it we're not
gonna We're Not Gonna Touch by going
forward you can buy more than like
whatever two properties per entity yeah
oh I I like that well then then you're
giving a massive layup to those who
already own multiple units though right
but it's better than nothing I I think
the better the better solution overall
is to tax it so much that it is
literally not viable to own multiple
units Beyond like the nest egg that you
have that is like your second house that
you're using as a as a as a vehicle for
a capital accumulation
so the people in the chat suggesting
that we should just heavily tax empty
units specifically that's a great idea
because yeah empty housing makes no
sense it's disgusting it's like a freak
[__] you just have it it is pretty gross
yeah that that would be a great there's
there's a massive warehousing problem in
New York for example they make it uh
they use
I mean these guys are real predatory
they use every legal move in the a
positive direction uh to their benefit
you know what I mean like they'll be
like rent stabilization in uh certain
areas and if if you have a rent control
building then you sit on it and you try
to make sure that every single person
living in those rank controlled units
eventually leave right uh if you have a
hold out you're kind of [__] but most
people don't want uh to live under like
shitty conditions where the house is
like not being uh uh your your unit is
not being fixed or whatever right and
then they just sit on it and they wait
uh and they Warehouse that unit or make
it impossible to rent uh because there's
like mixed income uh housing
restrictions that you have in places
like New York where you build a
skyscraper a certain percentage of that
I think 10 has to be like affordable
units specifically they usually have a
second elevator for the Poor's actually
uh if you're lucky enough to be able to
get into one of those units as a matter
of fact because there's a lottery for it
but
what they will try to do is like if
there's new available rent controlled
units uh that are in the market they
make it almost impossible to to to get
the unit because they put like the
fattest of down payments like you have
to put like a down payment that's like
three months rent which if you're
looking for affordable units you don't
have that kind of [__] money to begin
with so they they use every initiative
to their advantage uh and engage in
regulatory capture uh but that's not you
know other people I know in La that live
in rent controlled houses are like
um I would say doing extremely well and
don't need it do you know that have you
seen that like I know of people that
live in rent controlled houses and
they're like
you know personally so yeah that has
that and they've lived there for like
five to ten you just stay there forever
yeah oh yeah they got more money they're
probably making a combined income of
like you know over 200 000. I think
that's pretty funny because like when
you it almost feels like when you take
away one of the financial burdens of
like the most significant financial
burden which most Americans dump half of
their uh salaries into immediately
[Music]
I feel no hope
of those oh God that was such a nice
conclusion in the conversation too and
we were saying he says we need to
decommodify housing I said I totally
agree okay then I said we need to blank
nope it's funny because like uh there's
a clip of me talking to my friend at the
time who is a [__] landlord out there
from like five years ago when people
always point to that and he's like he's
a radical he's a radical and it's like
no there is a there isn't
it's always the same Dynamic of like
constantly saying well what about if
people don't comply with the law well
then yeah the state is needs to enforce
uh the rule of law like we do that every
[__] day for the Working Poor why
can't we do that for rich people ever
all right which is by the way I wasn't
the one who said anything about
landlords he was yeah I just want to
point that out I said let's take him out
here this what I want to do to landlords
take them out to dinner and ask them to
be reasonable with us and exactly okay
this is what ocean that's amenable to
All Parts
hold on
landlords watching this right now
oh God here we go
dude come on come on me a landlord all
right this episode we gotta go it's 12
30.
yeah all right
thanks for watching Everybody thanks for
playing
spot the Socialist that's right we're
sending government officials to their
house later today to re-educate them oh
yeah that we can re-up vacation baby I
think it's very good re-education
reintegration here today at the L
leftovers podcast
watch out uyghurs
that's right we got our eye on you
all right thanks for watching everybody
thank you to Hassan we didn't get to the
auto strike we were having too much fun
guys too much fun
excellent uh we'll see you next week for
leftover see you tomorrow everyone else
on much better until tomorrow yeah for
sure obviously yeah and uh thank you
everyone have a great day
don't we
[Music]
[Applause]